The joe rogan experience.
So in part there's an empirical question here,
which I don't know the answer to.
In Europe,
they ban in most of them they ban hate speech.
So a or you know,
a Holocaust denial.
There's certain things that are illegal.
It's a crime.
Um,
and in America we don't,
now it's an empirical question,
meaning it's open to actual investigation.
Um,
does banning it,
push it underground and let the people feel that they are victims of being
silencing something come back stronger or is certainly the best disinfectant.
Um,
I don't know the answer to that.
I think in general,
I think the American system has worked better,
but I don't know their scholars who could,
who could address that as for what is happening to the left is the left more
intolerant.
Um,
I,
I agree with you that you would think the left would be more open and in my
research on left,
right,
the left is generally higher and openness to experience the idea of dissent.
Dissent is patriotic.
These are leftist ideas,
not,
not right.
This idea.
So the left,
it should be more open.
Problem is any group that,
any group that loses a variety that loses diversity,
any group in which everybody thinks the same is at risk of,
of turning it into an ideology of turning to her religion.
Uh,
and then you lose the ability to think straight.
And now if somebody,
so you know,
when I was in college at Yale,
you know,
everybody sort of leaned left,
but there was,
they were conservatives,
there were some conservative professors,
like I'd been exposed to some conservative ideas.
But now if you're in a college that has essentially no conservatives that we'll
put out ideas and you encounter one,
now it's much more painful.
It's much more shocking.
Again,
it's like,
it's like you have a peanut allergy to ideas that are not your groups and we
want,
so we,
it's terrible if we're putting young people in systems that are basically giving
them ideological peanut allergies,
but most fighters are hard headed and are in a position to be hardheaded.
And that's like the hard part is like you trying to tell them,
listen,
you need to listen to me right now.
And like,
no,
I got this.
And then their careers just,
it's crazy cause that's what made them a fighter in the first place.
Right.
Tell him to fuck off.
That's it.
Stepfather beat their ass and they left the house and there's 16 fucked you.
I'll show the world fucking girl,
don't dumb in high school.
And
then next thing I know I'm out there and then fucking get in the cage.
I feel bad for dudes who didn't get dumped.
I do.
Why that?
Cause it's good for you.
Yeah.
It taught me a lot,
man.
I remember my girlfriend in high school and dumped me.
I was devastated for months.
Just devastated.
But then I realized like what the Fuck is wrong with me?
And I thought,
imagine if I'd married that girl magic.
I've had kids with her and Ooh.
And every day was just torture her bitching at me and controlling and oh I got
light,
I got off light.
Well here's one for you to enjoy.
Well,
same thing happened to me.
I got dumped in high school.
Yeah.
The girl started dating another dude.
I ended up hitting this motherfucker and hit with a wrench.
Yeah.
And I hit the motherfucking hair with a wrench.
Why'd you hit him in the head with a wrench?
He pissed me off.
Oh,
he pissed me.
He made me so mad.
Did he make you mad cause he was banging the grow or do you make you mad on top
of that?
Oh,
on top of that.
Yeah.
So I ended up hitting him and then I ended up going to jail to,
and I ended up doing 52 weekends in jail.
Damn.
But within that time,
every week,
every weekend I had to go in on Friday,
four year,
come out on Sunday for a year.
So I couldn't leave.
I couldn't leave my city.
So in that time I taught myself how to fight.
That's why I'm here today.
Wow.
And during the weekends?
No.
So,
uh,
during the week,
cause I couldn't leave,
so I would just,
I work.
And then me and Paul Rodriguez,
he fought 20 to Susan,
Uc 30 to me and him.
We trained them,
we taught ourselves how to fight in the backyard,
watching videotapes.
Wow.
Tony de Souza,
the originator of the Peruvian necktie.
Yep.
That's what I came from.
Is that really what I came for us?
He's proven.
No kidding.
That's where it came from.
Yeah.
That Peruvian necktie is a mother fucker.
That's a great move.
That was Tony Shit.
Yeah,
I incorporate that.
And on one of my systems,
man,
I loved that movie was a hell of a grappler.
Yeah.
So he ended up choking out a Paul Rodriguez,
UFC 32 and that was in that I got knocked out by Bj.
Wow.
But it all happened because I got dumped.
That's crazy.
Well,
it's just one of those things where you,
when you,
when you look back and you think of all the great things that you did
accomplish,
then you realize that you're retired at 30.
Yeah.
So much,
so much room there,
you know,
thirties so young.
You're in your athletic prime.
They,
I think they say 32 for a professional fighter.
They consider most athletic primes.
Right.
It's that
32.
It was,
but you know,
uh,
I look back on it and again,
you know,
the 42 fights,
that's a lot of fights.
Um,
plus I started when I was nine.
I had a little over a hundred amateur fights during,
there was a lot with that.
I mean,
for a while there'd be a while before I retired.
I was throwing it around,
you know,
retiring.
I was one of them guys that just,
I liked it and I loved it,
but I also sometimes got tired of it.
I'm a very simple guy and,
and uh,
it don't,
I don't care about the Glam or to fame or any of that.
I truly don't,
you know,
like even now what my,
my podcast and what I'm doing with some of these other adventures because I got
bored and I'm on to have fun.
Right.
You know what I mean?
And keep myself busy.
And,
um,
I've been fortunate to have what I have to be able to do all this on my own,
you know,
and go out there and be around everybody.
But yeah,
so when I was fighting,
you know,
there was a lot of rumors around up to retirement,
this,
that,
and I think the final icing on a cake was we were supposed to fight Andre Ward
and that's when Andre Ward ended up getting a sh,
a shoulder surgery.
And that flight fell through.
And I had been out in California training or an Ochsner trainer for almost a
year,
which fighters leave at the beginning of their career.
You know,
when they don't have a family,
when they're not making the money,
that's our opportunity to try and go and make money that when you're 12 years
into it,
you know.
And uh,
so I went out there and that kind of took a little bit from here as far as the
sport,
even though I loved it and it was great training with Robert Garcia.
I learned so much that didn't think I could learn at that point in my career.
And when that,
that Andre Ward fight fell through,
um,
I was,
I was done.
I mean,
I was,
I rolled over,
I never forget,
I rolled over and told my wife,
I said,
I think I'm done.
And she goes,
what are you talking about?
And as,
and I think I'm retiring and she started crying tears of joy because she wanted
me to be done even before that.
She don't know to sport or what,
what prime ages or not.
And uh,
I hung them up and,
and you know,
over the years,
as we talked earlier here who I would get the itch,
you know,
and that could have been just going to the gym and Aetna are doing around on the
pads.
But I,
I just didn't ever want it to keep doing it.
You know,
my health,
believe it or not is more important than anything else.
Spaces fake.
No,
I,
this is different than the flat earthers little Hashtag spaces,
fake hashtag spaces.
Faith is people that are so fucking stupid.
The flat earthers kicked him out.
Oh my God.
For real flat earthers kicked out the space.
Fake people spaces fake is,
oh my God,
they're the most skeptical.
So what would be the upper atmosphere?
Would be the edge.
It's all bullshit.
It's all fake.
It's the end.
It's tied in some weird way to religion,
which is really interesting because even the flat earth people,
there's a tremendous amount of them that are extremely religious and they talk
about the from Amen,
the Bible and the Bible,
and that this is a,
this is what's really going on is that they're trying to keep us from the
knowledge that God has created.
This place is a very special place.
Right,
and so by pretending that it's round,
they somehow or another are controlling us.
We're thinking that we're not exceptional and we're not lucky space.
It's fake.
They're using a video from that Ryan Gosling's movie he just made about Neil
Armstrong,
the first man on the moon.
Yeah.
Just be like this.
Look,
look,
here's proof.
[inaudible] fake everything.
They're making a movie because of the way they made the movie is that's evidence
that it's fake.
That because he's wearing it.
I don't know if maybe this person doesn't recognize that as being Ryan Gosling
right there.
She's got an NASA suit on.
Maybe it's just a troll account.
This is how NASA fix everything.
This is the video I was talking about guys.
Now you know it's all a big act passed.
This is fake.
Click on spaces fake though.
Oh,
that's what,
this is what I'm on.
I'm on the whole yeah,
but I mean click on it because there's a bunch of other warm on that thread.
There's a tremendous amount of people that literally believe that space is not
real.
I think it's like that with alligators in Florida tail.
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
they were,
uh,
an endangered species.
They would ask us to please not feed them marshmallows.
Cause I lived in Gainesville right by this place called Lake Alice Lake outside
alligators.
Fucking 11 years old.
I was living an alligator's.
It was
crazy.
It was a goddamn dinosaur.
But there was a small population of them cause they had been whacked into
oblivion before and people would make it suitcases out of him.
And then they made it illegal to hunt them and they made him a protected
species.
But then they fucked up.
They over protected.
And those goddamn super lizards are everywhere now.
Fucking everywhere.
My mom belongs to a golf course down in Florida where she lives.
And there's this alligator's apparently like this fucking 14 foot alligator.
And uh,
the people were playing golf and there was a deer.
And everybody's on the,
everybody's standing there going like,
it's a deer.
It's a deer.
Look at that beautiful fucking alligator comes out,
grabs it,
pulls it into the water,
does that spin move?
Takes it to the bottom.
Fucking done.
So everyone's talking about it.
What do we do about it?
So about three weeks later,
my mom is out on the course and her ball is right next to the lake where the
alligator is and she forgets and she goes over and her ball is right on the edge
and she's standing there and she was standing on some fucking like dead,
some dead grass.
And he gave out and she fell in the fucking lake up to her neck.
And then she remembered and she fucking started scrambling up the mud and
grabbing at the reeds to get out of there.
And,
and,
and the people that she was with had left,
she was playing by herself for some reason and she fucking got out of there and
got in the cart and,
and then she just started laughing.
Oh my God.
You believe that shit.
My little mother,
my little five foot two mother,
oh my God.
Would have been a tasty meal happened so quick.
Yeah.
Better than a dear old lady.
Nice.
Soft.
A lady.
Way more tender.
Yeah.
Corn Fed.
My mom's corn fed.
I never told you that.
Yeah.
I thought she was organic now.
Now we let her free range sometimes.